I have Tom Cruise and I'm Doug Liman and
we're doing a wired autocomplete
interview let's go guys ready
so can Tom Cruise really sing uh uh well
yeah I mean I did all my singing in Rock
of Ages so yes I sing I've seen him do
it Kent Tom Cruise rock climb yes I
trained for a long time many years
actually with rock climbing Ken Tom
Cruise play guitar I love playing guitar
and the uke I definitely need more
practice but I enjoy playing guitar ken
Tom Cruise fly a plane yes yes I fly
airplanes
I'm a multi-engine instrument-rated
commercial pilot Doug and I are both
aviators so we both love to fly ken Tom
Cruise hold his breath for six minutes
yes I can hold my breath for six minutes
you were there when I was doing it you
were in the tank and in leaves it in
London you'd swim back and forth in the
bottom of the tank like four or five
laps as well and I'd be up on the
surface with goggles watching him I
wasn't even working on the movie I just
wanted to watch Tom Cruise hold his
breath for six minutes
Kent Tom Cruise fly a helicopter yes
again I fly a helicopter I fly
aerobatics in that and commercially
rated and helicopter pilots I was in a
helicopter if you were the first time
you were really learning to fly yeah
that was that was you've come a long way
of saying I trained very hard
dad why are pilots seats furry mine
aren't maybe I don't know you sit for a
long time and you get sweaty but Tom
Cruise of course does not sweat
this one's really why do pilots usually
fly in the stratosphere
well aerobatic pilots don't necessarily
ya know the american-made flying was was
low I mean you're always like a few feet
over the treetops or a few feet over the
water so then sometimes actually going
through the trees why our pilots called
pilots ah you got all these smart come
on these questions like stratosphere I
mean like nautical why pilots can't be
colorblind she's like
seriously laughs this thing is right
that's just Naval Air Force you know
military pilots I think well there's one
thing you lose already communication
they have to flash a light gun from the
control tower and green means land and
red means don't Lancer maybe there
why do pilots say Niner I can answer
this one go
cuz over the radio it can be hard to
sort of understand you say nine or
instead of nine so that it wouldn't be
confused with a different number and
what number would that be confused with
nine like one two three four five six
seven eight nine when we why don't we
say aider for one or two her I actually
think I was right I was sounding smart
until you challenged me there why is Tom
Cruise always running I'm usually in a
big hurry to get places lots to do in
the day why is Tom Cruise always named
Jack because it's easy for me to
remember and for others to remember the
name Jack so makes it easier for the
crew and the director why did Tom Cruise
become an actor I just love movies and I
wanted to make movies and I remember as
a kid I used to create characters and
write skits and I always kind of did
outrageous physical stunts also you only
imagined would like to bend your mother
I feel I mean just look out the window
while you're doing the dishes and
there's your seven-year-old son like
trying a stunt and breaking an arm or a
leg is yes you were injuring yourself
all the time my mother
most definitely had incredible patience
did Tom Cruise really hang off the plane
yes I did hang off the a 400 I remember
the second take actually when we went
through it I got hit with just a little
little rock I mean it must have been
about that big and I honestly was like
getting hit by a bullet but the thing I
was most concerned about was a fuel
you know the fumes from that in the air
that was hitting me particularly on them
when we were taxing on the runway
because it had nowhere else to go
it's quite an adventure don't
necessarily recommend it for everyone
you know who's interesting our action
movies realistic yeah I think they are I
mean that's really the challenge of
making a great action film is to find
the honesty at it our action movies good
for a date yeah they're great for a
doubt our action will be scary can be I
mean I think that's a visceral ride you
get you know what it actually mean
that's that's probably like Tom and I
probably love make
you know when you really hit it you can
you can turn it into comedy you can
twist it into interesting drama how
actual movies are made I made action
isn't anything unless you really have
the story and the investment in
character and the thing that I love
about Doug Liman in his movies is the
interest first and foremost in character
and when you have Tom Cruise in your
movie it's you're gonna know you're
gonna get something incredible and it's
it's gonna be real that's where you try
we just want to entertain you that
really is the purpose so you know we we
hope you enjoyed